Star Wars - two buckets 8:1 hello I'm
George Lucas creator of Star Wars and
the even better
Star Wars special edition I handed off
my duties to JJ Abrams a very talented
director before I did that I made a few
final tweaks to the original Star Wars
so that you the fans could see it as it
was originally intended starring me so
without further ado please enjoy this
special sneak peek wipe no my father
didn't fight in the wars he was a
navigator on a spice freighter that's
what your uncle told you actually he was
a really good pod racer and he built
c-3po when he was nine but no one knew
the force as well as your father did the
force yeah the force it's a measurement
of someone's medical Orient count some
people say it's a power that surrounds
us binds the universe together it's
really just a metaphor thing there is a
great disturbance in the force I have
filled it we have a new enemy so I will
need you to build at least four more
death stars as you wish also your
lightsaber battles are getting boring do
a bunch of flips and choke them out a
couple times and spin around do
something fancy as you wish and you must
find the great char Jar Binks he cannot
fight but boy is he hilarious can we
find Jar Jar Binks he will join us or
die Master
oh look you came my hero Oh save me save
me Luke Oh
[Music]
[Music]